pero por periodos cortos solamente.
La mayoría tratarán de resistir o evitar la pérdida de agua.
Ejemplos extremos los podemos encontrar en plantas suculentas.
Tienden a ser pequeñas, muy atractivas,
pero se aferran a su agua a tan alto costo
que crecen muy lentamente.
Los árboles y arbustos evitan la pérdida de agua.
Envían raíces muy profundas,
minan suministros de agua subterráneos
y mantienen el flujo en todo momento,
manteniéndose hidratados.
El de la derecha es un baobab.
También se le llama el árbol al revés,
simplemente porque la proporción de las raíces con las ramas es tan grande
que parece que el árbol se plantó al revés.
Y, por supuesto, se requieren las raíces para la hidratación de esa planta.
Y probablemente la estrategia más común se encuentra en las plantas anuales.
Las anuales son la mayoría de nuestros alimentos vegetales.
En la costa oeste de mi país,
durante gran parte del año no se ve mucha vegetación.
Pero al llegar las lluvias de primavera, se ve esto:
flores en el desierto.
La estrategia de las plantas anuales,
es crecer solo en la temporada de lluvias.
Al final de esa temporada producen semillas,
que están secas, con entre 8% y 10% de agua,
pero muy vivas.
Y cualquier a cosa que esté seca y aún con vida,
la llamamos tolerante a la desecación.
En estado desecado,
las semillas pueden sobrevivir en condiciones extremas
por períodos prolongados de tiempo.
con la siguiente temporada de lluvias,
germinan y crecen,
y todo el ciclo comienza de nuevo.
Se cree ampliamente que la evolución de semillas tolerantes a la desecación
permitió la colonización y la expansión
de plantas con flores o angiospermas, hacia la tierra.
Regresemos a que las anuales son nuestro principal suministro de alimentos.
El trigo, el arroz y el maíz forman el 95% de nuestros alimentos vegetales.
Y ha sido una buena estrategia
porque en poco tiempo se pueden producir muchas semillas.
Las semillas son ricas en energía y hay gran cantidad de calorías,
se pueden almacenar en tiempos de abundancia para los tiempos de escasez,
pero hay un inconveniente.
Los tejidos vegetales,
las raíces y hojas de las plantas anuales,
no tienen por sí solas
características inherentes de resistencia o tolerancia.
Simplemente no las necesitan.
Crecen en temporada de lluvias
y tienen una semilla para sobrevivir el resto del año.
Y así, a pesar de los esfuerzos conjuntos en la agricultura
para hacer cultivos con propiedades mejoradas
de resistencia, evasión y tolerancia,
particularmente la resistencia y la evasión
porque hemos tenido buenos modelos para entender cómo funcionan,
todavía nos llegan imágenes como esta.
Cosecha de maíz en África,
dos semanas sin lluvia
y está muerta.
Hay una solución:
plantas de resurrección.
Estas plantas pueden perder el 95% de su agua celular,
permanecer en un estado seco, muerto, durante meses o años,
y al darles agua,
reverdecen y comienzan a crecer de nuevo.
Como las semillas, son tolerantes a la desecación.
Como las semillas, pueden soportar condiciones ambientales extremas.
Y es un fenómeno muy raro.
Solo hay 135 especies de plantas con flores que pueden hacer esto.
Voy a mostrarles un vídeo
del proceso de resurrección de estas tres especies
en ese orden.
Y en la parte inferior,
hay un eje de tiempo para que puedan ver lo rápido que pasa.
(Aplausos)
Bastante impresionante, ¿cierto?
Me he pasado los últimos 21 años tratando de entender cómo lo hacen.
¿Cómo se secan estas plantas sin morir?
Y trabajo con diferentes plantas de resurrección,
mostradas aquí en los estados hidratados y secos,
por distintas razones.
Una es que cada una de estas plantas sirve como modelo
para un cultivo que me gustaría hacer tolerante a la sequía.
En el extremo superior izquierdo, por ejemplo, es una hierba,
se llama Eragrostis nindensis,
tiene un pariente cercano llamado Eragrostis tef...
muchos sabrán que "teff"
es un alimento básico en Etiopía,
libre de gluten,
y es algo que nos gustaría hacer tolerante a la sequía.
La otra razón para examinar varias plantas,
es que, al menos inicialmente,
quería averiguar: ¿hacen lo mismo?
¿todas utilizan los mismos mecanismos
para ser capaces de perder toda esa agua y no morir?
Hice lo que llamamos un enfoque de la biología de sistemas
con el fin de obtener una comprensión global
de la tolerancia a la desecación,
en donde nos fijamos en todo
desde la molécula a la planta entera, el nivel ecofisiológico.
Por ejemplo nos fijamos en
los cambios en la anatomía de las plantas al secarse
y su ultraestructura.
Vemos el transcriptoma, que es solo un término para una tecnología
con la que analizamos los genes
que se activan o se apagan por la desecación.
La mayoría de los genes codifican proteínas, así que vemos el proteoma.
¿Cuáles son las proteínas producidas en respuesta al secado?
Algunas proteínas codifican enzimas que hacen metabolitos,
así que nos fijamos en el metaboloma.
Esto es importante porque las plantas están sujetas al suelo.
Utilizan lo que yo llamo un arsenal químico altamente sintonizado
para protegerse de todas las tensiones de su entorno.
Así que es importante ver
los cambios químicos implicados en el secado.
Y en el último estudio que hacemos a nivel molecular,
nos fijamos en el lipidome,
el lípido cambia en respuesta al secado.
Y eso es también importante
porque todas las membranas biológicas están hechas de lípidos.
Se usan como membranas porque están en el agua.
Al quitar el agua, estas membranas se destruyen.
Los lípidos también actúan como señales para activar genes.
Luego usamos estudios fisiológicos y bioquímicos
para tratar de entender la función de los protectores putativos
que descubrimos en nuestros otros estudios.
Y entonces utilizamos todo eso para tratar de entender
cómo la planta enfrenta su entorno natural.
Siempre he tenido la filosofía de que necesitaba una comprensión global
de los mecanismos de tolerancia a la desecación
para hacer una aportación significativa para una aplicación biótica.
Estoy segura de que algunos están pensando,
"Mediante recurso biótico,
¿significa que va a hacer cultivos modificados genéticamente?"
Y la respuesta es:
depende de su definición de modificación genética.
Todos los cultivos que comemos hoy en día, trigo, arroz, maíz,
están muy modificados genéticamente de sus antepasados,
pero no los consideramos así
porque se producen con el cultivo convencional.
Si se refieren a poner genes de plantas de resurrección en los cultivos,
la respuesta es sí.
Durante todo este tiempo, hemos usado ese enfoque.
Más precisamente, algunos de mis colaboradores en la UCT,
Jennifer Thomson, Suhail Rafudeen,
han encabezado este enfoque
y voy a mostrarles algunos datos pronto.
Pero estamos a punto de embarcarnos en un enfoque muy ambicioso,
en la que tratamos de activar grupos enteros de genes
que ya están presentes en todos los cultivos.
Nunca están encendidos en condiciones de sequía extrema.
Por lo que deben decidir
si se deben llamar GM o no.
Les daré algunos de los datos de ese primer acercamiento.
Y para hacer eso
tengo que explicar un poco cómo funcionan los genes.
Como todos sabemos,
los genes están hechos de ADN de doble cadena.
Se enrolla muy estrechamente en los cromosomas,
están en todas las células de su cuerpo o en el cuerpo de una planta.
Al desenrollar el ADN, se obtiene los genes.
Y cada gen tiene un promotor,
que es un interruptor de encendido y apagado,
la región de la codificación del gen,
y también un terminador,
que indica el final de este gen y que el siguiente gen inicia.
Los promotores no son solo interruptores de encendido y apagado.
Por lo general requieren una afinación fina,
muchas cosas deben estar presentes y bien antes de encender el gen.
Lo que se hace típicamente en los estudios de biotecnología
es usar un promotor inducible
que sabemos cómo encenderlo.
Lo aparejamos a los genes de interés,
lo colocamos en una planta y vemos cómo responde la planta.
En el estudio del que les voy a hablar
mis colaboradores utilizaron un promotor inducido por la sequía,
que descubrimos en una planta de resurrección.
Lo bueno de este promotor es que no hacemos nada.
La planta en sí detecta la sequía.
Con esto llevamos genes antioxidantes de las plantas de resurrección.
¿Por qué genes antioxidantes?
Bueno, todo el estrés, sobre todo la sequía,
resulta en la formación de radicales libres,
o especies reactivas de oxígeno,
que son altamente perjudiciales y puede causar la muerte de los cultivos.
Lo antioxidantes detienen el daño.
Estos son algunos datos de una cepa de maíz muy usada en África.
A la izquierda de la flecha están las plantas sin los genes,
a la derecha,
plantas con genes antioxidantes.
Después de tres semanas sin riego,
los que tienen los genes se recuperan mucho mejor.
Para el enfoque final.
Mi investigación ha demostrado que hay una considerable similitud
en los mecanismos de tolerancia a la desecación
en semillas y plantas de resurrección. Así que me hice la pregunta,
¿utilizan los mismos genes?
O parafraseado,
¿las plantas de resurrección evolucionaron semillas con genes
tolerantes a la desecación en sus raíces y hojas?
¿Han reasignado la tarea de estos genes de semillas
en las raíces y las hojas de las plantas de resurrección?
Y respondo a esa pregunta,
gracias a una gran cantidad de investigación de mi grupo
y recientes colaboraciones de un grupo de Henk Hilhorst en los Países Bajos,
Mel Oliver en los Estados Unidos
y Julia Buitink en Francia.
La respuesta es sí,
hay un conjunto básico de genes que están involucrados en ambos.
Voy a ilustrar esto muy crudamente para el maíz,
donde los cromosomas desactivados
representan todos los genes requeridos para tolerar la desecación.
Al secarse las semillas de maíz, al final de su período de desarrollo,
se activan estos genes.
Las plantas de resurrección activan los mismos genes
cuando se secan.
Todos los cultivos modernos, por lo tanto,
tienen estos genes en sus raíces y hojas,
pero nunca los activan.
Solo se encienden en los tejidos de semillas.
Lo que estamos tratando de hacer ahora
es entender las señales ambientales y celulares
que activan estos genes en plantas de resurrección,
para imitar el proceso en los cultivos.
Un pensamiento final.
Lo que estamos tratando de hacer rapidamente es repetir
lo que la naturaleza hizo en la evolución con las plantas de resurrección
hace entre 10 y 40 millones de años.
Mis plantas y yo les damos las gracias por su atención.
(Aplausos)